glenn younkin will join us in just a
moment here on the show but first we
wanted to go as we always do and for
good reason to britt hume he is fox
news's senior political analyst he joins
us now bret thanks so much for coming on
last night as you were assessing what
might happen in this race you said if
mcauliffe loses
this is a massive story do you still
feel that way and if so how big
oh yeah i do tucker it was obviously a
broadly based protest vote against what
democrats see going on in washington
and it was also a very well engineered
campaign by candidate junkin himself who
positioned himself as a as a as an
obvious alternative as a completely
acceptable alternative to the democrat
mcauliffe one who did not seem an
extremist he didn't seem a trumpist he
didn't carry any of the baggage that can
hold republicans back and and and the
voters said okay and i accepted him and
huge upset um one that was not forecast
until only recent days
very skillful campaign by a novice
candidate
big hill to climb he climbed it
what's interesting though is that he
didn't run on tax cuts i i think that
was a feature of his
of his platform but he ran on what we
are told are the divisive social issues
critical race theory what our kids are
taught i mean he went right to the
things that people talk about on social
media
and he won on that what does that tell
you
well it tells you one thing and that is
that there's an argument about this
whole question of critical race theory
in this particular political race
and on one side and you're hearing it i
heard it all day to day i saw it
everywhere the critical race is not
taught in virginia schools critical race
theories not taught in virginia schools
the ap and the nbc are saying it it's
being said all everywhere on the left in
fact however there is ample evidence
that critical race theory very much
influences and and and is injected into
what is being taught in those schools
and these parents knew that they came to
know it it may have had something to do
with the kids being at home during the
pandemic and the and the and the kids
getting their parents getting a closer
look at what their kids were learning
but that but that was out there and the
parents were right and young kim was
right and the left and terry mccall's
and the rest of them were wrong on the
facts and as a result uh people people
weren't going to vote for somebody who
didn't think there was a problem um like
duncan did
you know so that that's that's where
that comes out and of course you know
you have people on the on the left and
some you know shin pullers saying well
it was the republicans who injected race
into this election bologna um the
critical race theory itself injects race
into the lives of our school children it
should never be and it should never have
any influence let alone being taught now
now people say you could say technically
tucker it's not being taught in the
sense that you know volumes have been
written on critical race theory and it's
not been handed out as a textbook but
its influence and its its tenants are in
those schools
i i've never figured out what critical
race theory is to be totally honest
after a year of talking about it they're
teaching that some races are morally
superior to others that some are
inherently sinful and some are
inherently saintly and that's immoral to
teach that because it's wrong how you
might be well i think most voters view
what's also
what's also wrong about it tucker is
that it it rests on this idea
that that racism and racial
discrimination permeates
the experience of citizens in america
that that we are inherently and almost
incurably racist and that it influences
everything and it sees the world through
that prism
it's misguided to say the very least and
people have had enough of it no doubt
about it in my mind
that's for sure finally brit hume great
to see you tonight thank you